okay now you'd say I was too close but
but David will fill what call a soft
wall he won't
F that hard wall so he won't press
against it because there's nothing
saying to him so he presses against it
as him pressing against me I'm not
fighting him I'm not going in out I'm
not
absorbing so that was one question the
next question go
L but he's such nice person anyhow but I
don't actually feel anything from him
because he's just blending with
me so there lies the question he's
blending with
me and what I'm saying
is I'm
l so I can't feel
so the question was I felt I felt
there's much stronger energy with John
than I did with Lawrence and I'm
going I'm hang on you
better I'm
law so it's a hard thing to get your
head round of course it is but I don't
need to win anymore I don't need to be
in the right place anymore I am in
wherever
he he she wants me to
be so when I
said when I when I
done this and you said you was too close
I'm not too close because this we could
put this paper between
us but the paper mustn't move towards
him if he wants to move into me then
that's that's his his prerogative but
I'm not move into his space if I want to
do K I can do K all I got to do is do it
mechanically so there's the technical
and there's the the just
knowing so that's the I don't expect you
to get but you
see it doesn't matter who grips me
that's what I try to said at the
beginning it doesn't matter who grips me
I don't feel them gripping
me how can I if I say
so I say how does that
feel CU I'm
him even though it's hard to get your
head round look to
me he he can do that to himself can't if
he wants he can bend he can fall down he
can do a new caming he can do that but
if I'm
Tony and I go right oh
oh this is a bit
different hang on get all the postures
right just I mean what what makes the
difference between that and
that it's CU I don't need to win I don't
need to
want I'm not saying You' got to get it
all I'm saying is if you want the bridge
from one from technical to ensi we have
to look
at how bad we
are we have to look at how bad we are at
wanting it I know already that I'm in
the wrong
place no I'm not going to tell you
what's in my head up there but I'm not
going to tell you what's in my head but
I'm in the wrong place because that
feels a little bit hard you see if I was
here see yeah there's no it's it's right
um
oh yeah right so what most of you are
doing wrong
technically
is your right
angles this this uh this won't work
because what you've done is you've moved
far too far see he's coming this way you
go please go
past see if you say or please go past
and you go here actually
he'll think that he knows I'm here so
he's not actually at ease because he
knows I'm here if I'm
here he think he's he's now wondering
what can he do is he free to go past
where you know has he got any
restrictions but I'm not in his way but
he's analyzing whether I am if I'm here
he knows that I might be perform
something out the
blue right I'm talking to you as
teachers you know you're not all I'm
trying to say to you when you wear the
teachers hat you're usually in a giving
mode but I want you to be in a mode
where you float and think go off
afterwards and go I don't know what I
experienced the night teaching but it
was as if they were actually doing the
technique for me or they were helping me
do the technique it's the same it's the
same as this if I go here hard already
if I go on the
outside see it's not
hard
so okay so so the angle to most of you
got the angle too far on this so into
that so right angles was hard it went
further in other words if Ray continued
his his cut and moving forward and
you're now virtually behind
it is there there's less conflict and
there's no softness right you didn't you
didn't get the moon but you didn't get
the
moon see
I'm you'd say I'm too close to him but
he doesn't feel that I'm impinging on
him if I added the slightest part piece
of
pressure he would now think you know I
might be resist this or I might just
mean so it's I mean I don't know why I
come up this butterfly thing but
it's it's it's so that he doesn't feel
any aggression from me
whatsoever and that's what I realized
cyto sense he had had in other words
they trained so hard so many years
brutally that in the end he just wanted
to do his iido he didn't he didn't want
any more hard Nikos or fighting and
that's why he was so powerful and that's
why he was so good because he's
Untouchable because is blending with the
person